Hi. In this video, we'll look at using Burp to help us guess usernames for known users.
Burp Intruder has a built-in username generator that takes an input and produces a list of
potential usernames using common patterns. For example, if you were to provide the input
Carlos Montoya, the generator would return Carlos.Montoya, mcarlos and similar combinations.
This is useful in circumstances where you know details of a specific user,
for example their name or email address, but don't know their exact username.
It provides a more targeted way of enumerating usernames than a generic name list.
If you'd like to follow along, you can use the Username Enumeration
Via Different Responses Lab from our Web Security Academy.
Once the lab has launched, we're just going to try and log in so we create a failure message
for the login mechanism.
Now we'll go to Burp's Proxy HTTP History tab and identify that failure message.
In the message, highlight the username value, right-click and choose Send to Intruder.
Go to the Intruder Positions tab and you'll see that because we highlighted it,
Burp has automatically added the username as a payload position.
Click the Intruder Positions tab and select Sniper from the Attack Type drop-down list.
Go to the Payloads tab and then choose Username Generator from the Payload Type drop-down.
Enter an input that you want to base the generated usernames on into the Enter a New Item field of the Payload
Settings section and click Add.
You can add multiple inputs per attack if required.
Enter the number of usernames you want Burp to generate into the Maximum Payloads Per Item field,
and Burp will generate this number of usernames for every input added.
Click Start Attack.
Intruder will generate its list of potential usernames and run an attack testing each one in turn.
Analyse the attack results to check for interesting patterns,
such as one of the usernames resulting in a different HTTP response code.
In this case, we can see one of the responses is longer.